Jean-François Copé vous êtes le meilleur
je l'ai dit de la ville de Meaux les
habitants les appellent les Meldois il y
a eu aucun jumelage entre les melda et
mon cul
Tom
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Comment ça va Thierry super
comme chaque semaine on va on va
débriefer les petits tweets de de la
semaine dernière n'hésitez pas à
commenter l'émission en direct #slt et
non pas Salut les Terriens exactement
voilà on les lira la semaine prochaine
alors la semaine dernière
vous avez fait vos premiers pas sur
Twitter c'est vrai j'ai envoyé mon
premier tweet
j'ai marqué merde à celui qui lira c'est
peut-être pas parce qu'il a mis voilà
bon non mais c'est bien c'est raccord
par rapport à Twitter c'est super alors
du coup le petit bémol c'est que vous
avez pas tweeté de la semaine Thierry ah
non bah oui mais il faut il faut que je
tweete Jean-François Patrick
selfie ouais tiens prenez votre portable
on va faire un selfie alors on va faire
c'est ça
on va le faire avec le mien ça sera plus
rapide
ouais mais cette cerveau le prix d'un
iPhone parce qu'il est fabriqué
spécialement maintenant
on est là sur la photo
oh nickel allez ça c'est fait je vous
l'envoie par fax et comme ça emballé
nous dévoilez pas tout tout de suite on
va pas tout savoir en tout cas parmi les
tweets spectateurs de la semaine
dernière un petit tweet a retenu mon
attention celui de Montel Doris qui nous
dit Salut les Terriens ça parle que de
cul maintenant bah c'est aussi ça
l'arrivée sur C8 il y en a encore qui
découvre Thierry Ardisson la semaine
dernière aussi on a reçu Miki Blanco
c'est un rappeur qui se déguise en femme
voilà en gros si vous aimez Céline Dion
et le basketteur Kobe Bryant voilà et
bah ça donne Miki Blanco
voilà hein et ce tweet nous rappelle que
le groupe Canal c'est aussi la chaîne du
foot comme le dit Marcel mccorto et il
nous dit pas top top la teinture blonde
de Brandao c'est le petit souci bon en
tout cas la semaine dernière à côté de
Micky Blanco il y avait aussi Henri
Guaino et Laurent Baffie qui s'est
incrusté et on a un très bon tweet de
Ark Angel regarder la photo qui nous dit
ils ont pris un coup de vieux les
inconnus
c'est aussi ça Twitter c'est des
gentillesse ouais n'hésitez pas à
commenter hashtag slt
[Applaudissements]
bah alors Tom
[Musique]
allez-y les gars
tu me rends que sur son génial mais moi
s'il y a pas la musique on me donne pas
l'eau
demander ma musique
et Jean-François Copé réunis après
guerre des keV Patrick et Jean-François
alors c'est le même principe les deux
sont marrants sauf qu'il y en a un qui
le fait pas toujours exprès bon bravo
d'abord honneur aux dames ancien
mannequin chanteuse chanteuse à voix ce
n'est pas Carla Bruni sinon j'aurais pas
dit à voix
peut-être pas dit chanteuse non plus
mesdames et messieurs il m'a dit
alors Imany à l'inverse de Renaud vous
avez commencé votre carrière dans les
bars
une belle voix une carrière en or vous
revenez avec votre deuxième album il
s'est passé cinq ans entre les le
premier et le deuxième album un
quinquennat voilà et vous avez dit sur
votre site 5 ans c'est long mais c'est
le temps qu'il faut pour ne pas tenter
de vous décevoir vous savez que parfois
il faut beaucoup moins de 5 ans pour
décevoir des gens ça c'est alors avant
d'être chanteuse vous avez fait plein de
petits boulots quand vous étiez à New
York vous avez même distribué des tracts
déguisés en perroquet c'est pas un petit
boulot hein c'est un enterrement de vie
de jeune fille en fait ça c'est
notre prochaine invité c'est celui qui
rigole de tout avec n'importe qui mais
surtout celui qui paye c'est Patrick
Timsit
[Applaudissements]
Patrick vous revenez pour deux dates
spéciales avec votre spectacle à la
salle Pleyel votre spectacle s'appelle
on ne peut pas rire de tout et c'est
vrai que c'est une excellente question
aujourd'hui avec tous les événements
qu'on a vécu tu vas Peut-On rire de tout
après ça dépend de quoi tu parles bien
entendu il y a des gens dont c'est pas
dangereux de se moquer tu en peux se
soudoyer tu sais pas moi des sourds
pour les raisons techniques évidentes
les SDF on peut se de la gueule
des SDF c'est vrai il y en a pas
beaucoup qui viennent voir les
spectacles les mecs font pas d'efforts
tu vois et puis si jamais il y en a un
qui vient tu le repère facilement c'est
le seul qui a 12 places de libre autour
de lui donc fatalement c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'a priori on peut se
moquer mais que si on fait partie de la
communauté c'est les Juifs sur les Juifs
les Arabes sur les Arabes les
Pakistanais sur les fleuristes donc
non mais si on part sur ce principe là
moi il y a pas de souci le truc c'est
que je suis blanc athée et terreau et
que je suis originaire la région
parisienne j'ai pas de points d'accroche
tu vois j'ai Dany Boon encore il a les
Ch'tis Titeuf il a les mecs au chômage
mais tu vois il y a pas de soleil il y a
pas de blanc qui fait de blague sur les
Arabes facilement mais
c'est pas le
[Applaudissements]
mais Patrick j'ai une question pourquoi
c'est toujours les Juifs qu'on le
monopole du malheur ça c'est quand même
attention je veux pas dormir avec la
lycra je veux pas qu'il me mette un
process une association qui a un nom de
tissu en plus oui alors l'association
qui défend les Juifs elle a un nom de
tissu et bravo les clichés même la
guitare vraiment bravo
et pour terminer Jean-François Copé
alors vous êtes le maire de Meaux vous
avez été lu mère à l'âge de 31 ans c'est
pas mal bon Sarkozy lui il a été élu à
l'âge 28 ans maire de Neuilly en même
temps Nicolas il a tout fait avant vous
savez mère ministre président même le
tribunal il a fait avant vous ça c'est
vrai que c'est pas alors vous avez
disparu 18 mois des radars à cause de
l'affaire Bygmalion alors on rappelle
juste en deux mots l'affaire Bygmalion
il y a des mecs à l'UMP qui ont signé
des chèques pour la campagne de Sarkozy
sauf que vous étiez pas au courant et
comme vous étiez président de l'UMP
c'est vous qui avez trinqué pour pour
les autres ça je trouve ça dégueulasse
moi j'ai un conseil pour pas se
retrouver dans une embrouille c'est pas
faire président de l'UMP ça c'est comme
ça c'est vrai que c'est toujours sur les
MP que ça tombe cette malédiction c'est
on dit toujours que la foudre ne frappe
jamais de faux au même endroit mais à
priori la justice elle frappe souvent à
l'UMP c'est non attention je ne fais pas
d'amalgame je ne suis pas de ceux qui
disent politique sont tous pourris non
non il y en a aussi qui sont pas chopés
donc
je vous rassure Jean-François on
reparlera pas de cette affaire des pains
au chocolat on remarquera juste que
comme Joe Dassin c'est pas ce que vous
avez fait de mieux alors Jean-François
Copé vous êtes candidat à la primaire de
droite et parmi vos propositions vous
voulez supprimer le droit du sol et
mettre à la place une nationalité
d'adhésion oui alors on explique
rapidement ce que c'est c'est en gros si
vous êtes né de parents étrangers en
France lorsque vous avez 18 ans vous
devenez français seulement sur la base
d'une demande et si vous remplissez les
conditions alors les conditions il y a
maîtriser la langue française adhérer
aux valeurs de la République et avoir un
casier judiciaire vierge alors ça bon ça
c'est plus délicat parce que du coup qui
va être maire de Levallois du coup on
sait pas encore ça c'est le
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
tirer Ardisson
ne veut toujours pas vous poser du coup
c'est moi qui m'y colle Imany il m'a mis
votre chanson don't be so shy a fait un
carton ça fait 160 millions de vues sur
Youtube est-ce que c'est vraiment un
gage de qualité quand on voit que
andalouse de kendji est à 190 millions
absolument pas
on contrôle pas c'est comme ça Patrick
Timsit Patrick vous venez de tourner la
suite de stars 80 alors sans nous
spoiler ce que c'est vrai que dans le
film Jean-Luc Lahaye enfin en prison
aucune raison
et pour terminer Jean-François Copé vous
êtes le meilleur je l'ai dit de la ville
de Meaux les habitants les appellent les
Meldois il y a eu aucun jumelage entre
les mails et mon cul
comme vous le savez
on y est là et pour tout vous dire
puisque vous me cherchez
sauf que je suis fils de proctologue
pour de ne rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu